up next an encore book notes interview
with retired army colonel david
hackworth his book about face details
the us military involvement in vietnam
mr hackworth was the army's youngest
colonel and is one of america's most
decorated living soldiers the interview
is about an hour
your new book about face the odyssey of
an american warrior is co-written by
julie sherman a woman why
well i had a lot of people
over the
18 years of rumination i thought thought
about writing this book a lot of authors
come to came to me and asked
to write it with me are for me
and i waited for the right one
and uh julie sherman came along and uh
after looking at her work
and uh talking to her i concluded that
what i really needed was the a woman's
feel a woman's touch
war is about men and men take life but
the end
horrible result about war
is
it takes
the life of young men in the main and
it's the sons the daughter of the
daughters the husbands of of women women
give life
and i felt that if we could discuss war
and discuss it with that man's passion
from my own experience but with the
sensitivity
and that depth and feeling of a woman we
could tell the complete story
how many times during those 18 years
since you left the army
did you seriously consider writing this
book oh probably a half dozen there were
a number of of that qualified people
that came to me
but i wanted i wanted also to to ensure
that
i had my head together so my the message
that i was going to give uh would be
clear and would be objective and would
be without bitterness and vindictiveness
and the
the the need to
even the score
at the end of the whole book some 875
pages your last line says something
about
you think you've got the anger out of
your system when were you the most angry
and why are you angry
well
in 1971 i said that
to the nation
that
vietnam was a bad war
and i said it with from my heart
from the experiences of
almost six years
over a six year period in vietnam that
it was a bad war we were losing it we
were bleeding unnecessarily and there
was just simply no way we were going to
win it nor our
people that we were involved with the
south vietnamese were going to win it
and we should get out now and
what i didn't realize that when you
sound off
against a big institution like the u.s
army and say they're all wrong i didn't
realize what happened to whistleblowers
and i got thumped about the head and
shoulders in a very severe way
and that created the bitterness and uh
that
that caused me to
leave america leave my roots and go to
australia and be angry for a long time
were you angry at all before you made
those pronouncements on issues and
answers
well i certainly was uh
you know in 1966 i told the army chief
of staff harold k johnson we were losing
the war in 1968 i wrote in a paper which
went to general westmoreland that we'd
botched the war the following year in 69
i told the secretary of the army stanley
rieser that we were losing the war and i
told anybody and everybody that would
listen to me i wrote this in army
publications it was uh pretty evident
where i was coming from but nothing was
done i took a drafty battalion
full of untrained kids in 69 and turned
them into a praetorian guard that just
turned the battlefield around and at the
end of a five-month period we'd killed
2500 enemy at the loss of 25 of my men
100 to 1 ratio we were fighting the war
as the war should have been fought but
no one listened no general came down and
said gee how did you guys do this how
did these untrained troopers win battles
like this time and time again
because we didn't want to learn the
government the army specifically has no
real deep reflection they just don't
look at the past to to learn from it to
grow from it and i think that's the
thing that as it build up this
frustration caused me to sound off you
know as a little kid
when i was 15 i was in italy and general
eisenhower who was a five-star general
stopped in front of me and probably
because i was just a little 15-year-old
kid he said well how do you like it here
son and i said oh just fine general and
he said how's the chow you know normal
thing a general is going to ask a little
bit i said oh that's terrible
we spam every day and he went down the
line and he said why do these guys eat
spam every day and you know went from
the lieutenant general to the major
general to down to the little major the
reply came bundling up oh the depot
from the war is filled with spam we got
to get rid of it so ike said stop it
give these guys you know fresh food and
so on so i've from that point forward as
long as i was a soldier i sounded off if
i saw something wrong i told him so when
i look back
i reflect that my sounding off in 71 i
tried it through the system i told
everybody in the army that would listen
to me when i realized that that wasn't
going to happen i went to the people
via the media and told them the truth of
what was happening in vietnam
what were you doing in the army when you
were 15 years old
i was interested in sex and adventure
and that seemed to me the army provided
could you get in the army when you were
15. if you lied
and i had been in the merchant marine
for a year before so i had merchant
papers from my experience in the pacific
and so i used those as a documents to
get me in the army i was an orphan so it
was uh
it was the army became a home for me
brian it became a
my family was something i loved very
very much so i was very protective
towards this institution and i always
loved my soldiers because i was a
soldier and i wanted to keep them alive
i believed
in winning battles and and fighting wars
and i was a warrior but not at the
expense of my men so i think that great
love for my soldiers was the thing too
that made me stand up and and shout stop
the madness
do you think if you were if you had
written a book
and i know you talked about the korean
war in your book and the vietnam war i
want to talk about the korean war in
just a second but if you basically said
the vietnam war was a good thing and we
did a good job that you'd be getting the
kind of reviews positive
praise for your book that you're getting
well
i don't know uh i would from certain
circles certainly the army magazine and
the institution would endorse what i
have to say
but
i think in the book is the truth and i
think that those people who are writing
the reviews
most of them had been on the battlefield
had gone through that same experience as
i
and uh they're just seeing somebody
finally
coming out in a in a real
detailed form and offering what happened
in vietnam and it just wasn't from
vietnam all this tragedy that occurred
started in 1946 when we took our officer
corps and started this business of
making everybody a diplomat and a
warrior and
which ended up under maxwell taylor when
he became cheapest out our generals
became corporate generals rather than
the fighting generals of the type that
won world war ii the ridgeways and the
patents and so on
what do you think of medals
battles uh i mean let me preface it by
saying when you read about your book and
about you they say you're the most
decorated man at the time of your
departure from the army in 1971 as
anybody in the history of the military
or just during the vietnam war well i
think it's in the his living history of
the u.s military
what do i think of medals i think that
napoleon said
if you have enough ribbon you can
conquer the world and i think you have
to honor your warriors for uh standing
up and being counted uh for moving into
the fire across the killing zone and you
honor them with a piece of ribbon and
at the end of world war ii
the household
name was audie murphy audie murphy had
what nine ribbons the medal of honor the
distinguished service cross the purple
heart silver star bronze star and so on
they were all awards for feats on the
battlefield during the korean war there
was a fellow right here in washington dc
named lives now named scooter burke
lloyd leslie burke who won all the
medals that audie murphy won he never
received any recognition because
that war the korean war was not a
glorious war we didn't win it it wasn't
uh there wasn't any berlins or tokyos or
so on and the same thing from the
vietnam war
those kids
that won awards for
attacking a machine gun or saving a
comrade that were
certainly to be honored and to be
recognized but there were so many others
that were the these self-serving
careerists general officers and colonels
and so on who used the award thing to
get an award simply just so it looked
good on his on his jacket which
would cause someone to think he was a
warrior and you look at you know take
admiral crowe
who is the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff on
his jacket it's a blaze with medals and
so on 31 of them but there's not one for
a combat deed they're all having been
their awards you're a good guy award you
move some paper across your desk in a
neat way award take oliver north who's
in the hot seat as we talk he
has 14 awards on his chest
but only three for combat the silver
star the brian star and the purple heart
the rest are having been their awards
and he appears in front of congress and
the american people think hey this is a
warrior just like when admiral crowe
perhaps appears in front of congress
those are his credentials and those
congressmen don't know they're just
having been their awards when he says we
need this they believe that he knows
what he's talking about from the
standpoint of being on a battlefield so
i think that we've we've kind of uh
put our award system at a cross
purpose granada there were 7 000 men on
that island they gave 8 000 awards there
were 200 anime cuban soldiers and so on
on that island and they gave 200 awards
for valor one person enemy soldier so
this is stretching it a bit far brian i
think we need to go back and clean up
our act on awards and just give awards
to soldiers the final line on awards is
to me the only award that is of today
because it's been considerably
prostituted that really means something
to warriors is the purple heart and
above that the combat infantry badge
that means i've been there in vietnam
there were 103 battalions of that
hundred battalions there was 1600 rifle
platoons so of the 550 000 men that
fought in vietnam that were in vietnam
that served in vietnam only 50 000 men
were infantry out fighting the enemy and
every time they put their foot down they
didn't know whether they were going to
have a foot a leg or life so i think
that
we have to look at metals in the
military and in vietnam from that
viewpoint that
it's become a big corporation rather
than a fighting institution and i think
we need to return our military
to a an organization that can serve and
defend our country without all these
games people play how many awards did
you win how many
rivens yeah i don't know
how many purple hearts eight now that
means something to me what'd you do the
first time you were wounded and where
was it
uh let's see i was a little kid in korea
uh was a squad leader of an f3 squad and
uh i was flushing out a sniper and uh
he's he got me first and the bullet
struck me in the back of the head and
came uh came out
uh under the skin of the back and uh
knocked me on my my tail and uh and i
thought it was dead ringing in the ear
and so on and i
my buddy that was with me that was
covering me thought i was dead with
blood spurting everywhere and it may
have knocked me out i don't know but
when i when i came to my senses i was by
myself and i uh crawled out of there i
was way out in front of the the
enemy lines and we had just killed three
enemy of machine gun crew on the on the
way and i
to way to get to this position where i
was firing at the sniper and i
had to crawl over these three fellas and
i knew they'd be alive and i in panic
had dropped my weapon uh so i i finally
crawled over them and got back to the
american lines and and was patched up
and back to the hospital
and
and i wanted to return because i wanted
to get back to
uh to my unit because it was my again
that point that i brought out earlier it
was my family the guys i really love
there's no bonding like that on the
battlefield that among combat
instruments can you remember you don't
have to go through this all these but
can you remember the other seven times
when you're wounded as clear as a bell
this is something i don't think you'd
ever forget
tell us a couple of them
oh jay well i i think they uh one time i
was lying in a position and we were
being shelled and my platoon started
flung his arm over my back and a shell
exploded right next to us and the
platoon started and said oh i'm hit and
uh and uh when things settle down we
started what you normally do is start
checking out your body because things
are thumping up against your dirt and so
on and just check out if you've been
wounded and i realized i hadn't and i
said well let's get out of here and
greer found that his arm was nailed to
my back and
the shrapnel had gone through his arm
and nailed it to my back so we had to
prize his arm from my back so that was
one that you know that i wouldn't forget
another time was on in korea again
in 1951
for november
i had a hand grenade blow up
underneath me and it blew me way up in
the air and flung me down on the ground
and tore my arm almost off and uh
and i thought i was gonna die in a
sergeant named jack speed from memphis
tennessee came running up and he said
well the old man's dead he says and i
thought never am i going to die on this
hill and i got up enough strength and
walk down to where the dock was patching
people up so you don't forget those
experiences and
it they all kind of happen in slow
motion brian
you recall the whole thing and it's
something it's like all of us have been
at one time another in danger of some
sort in an accident with a car and you
see that car swerving over and
everything slowed down and you could see
the other car coming and you think why
can't i stop
and that's the way combat is i think
when it comes to the time where you're
in the utmost danger your whole system
slows down where you're recording every
micro second of it
when do you remember in your life being
the most afraid or having the most fear
well on the battlefield you're uh
frightened all the time and you live
with it and the beauty of being a leader
of being a squad leader a platoon
sergeant company commander and so on was
you were busy you were looking after
your your troops shepherding your herd
so to speak you were calling in
artillery fire bringing an air
maneuvering a unit talking on the radio
and you simply didn't have time to be as
concerned as that warrior is who's just
waiting behind a wall for someone to say
let's get up and go so that's the the
real problem and another problem is the
brighter you are the more imagination
you have then the more things your brain
can conjure up that's going to happen to
you so if you're a doe foot and you're
not too clever you know you might make
it through the night without it without
a lot of stress and i think that one of
the things from vietnam is this vietnam
stress syndrome is that
those kids endured something that the
american soldier in the history of our
country from 1776 forward
didn't experience in battle and that was
that minute-to-minute experience of
walking through a a field laced with
booby traps that were carefully
camouflaged you know that 50 percent of
all casualties in vietnam came from
mines and booby traps and uh and i think
that that business
if you were lucky to survive for the 365
days that our infantry fought in vietnam
that would sear your mind and uh and i
think that
that is one of the the causes of a lot
of disturbances
among the men that fought in vietnam
tell our audience that we're talking
about this book right here about face
colonel david hackworth
along with uh julie johnson how
i mr sherman i'm sorry how did you write
this book
well it took five years brian five long
years and and what julie and i first did
was uh worked at a game plan we decided
to tape every experience that i had and
that before the taping
this is audio tape before the taping we
took all of the documents the notebooks
the papers the things i had saved
throughout my 25-year military
experience and we'd compartmentize that
in 18 chapters
that we assumed we envisioned we would
be writing 18 chapters and
maybe it was a notebook a little little
uh small book i'd carried in korea which
had only six or seven lines in it or a
letter from a friend or a letter that i
had sent home that was saved by my
brother or my sister-in-law or someone
and
once we
once we'd organized those 18 boxes of uh
of information then we went through
those and recorded those experiences and
then that became a transcript of about
this high of about
57 tapes worth and then julie went
through that and set out what the story
was and then she
would write a chapter and give me the
chapter
i would rewrite the chapter while she
was doing two i would be doing one and
then from that names would fall out we
only started with about three or four
names and we ended up with almost 400
people that contributed to the book
which made the book alive in that we
were drawing on the experiences on the
memories of a lot of other warriors and
so i was like then by the end of the
book driving the truck and there were
300 odd guys in the back of the truck
whose voices we could use and and added
to the wealth and the knowledge uh
that's contained in the book and the
accuracy too because your memory is a
funny thing and on the battlefield too
you can only see over the sights of your
rifle so you don't see the big picture
and we wanted to tell the big picture
as best we could so then
these chapters would go back and forth
and we'd integrate the input from the
letters from the people that we were
tracing down and we'd crank their stuff
into it and then the thing would be
rewrite rewritten and rewritten and
rewritten some chapters were written 20
times and
so that put a big strain on julie and i
there's a thing that julie is a
screenwriter
not a book writer and there's a thing in
her trade called abandon you just get so
much information and in my case i was so
passionate about the subject because i
felt the book would cause people to
learn the book would cause people not to
make those horrible mistakes again so i
wanted to get every little detail in so
i might like for example one chapter
which is called the wolf hounds which
deals with korea of 1950 and 51 and
early 52.
when it was completely done locked in
concrete i'd gotten some information
from the national archives that really
lent a lot of information to
that particular chapter and uh
and i went to julie i said look golly
this is great stuff we need to put it in
and she felt that we had reached a point
of abandonment on that chapter and so we
had that kind of friction of give and
take friction to get the book together
and get it done correctly
and that's why it took five years which
is a lot of your life where'd you write
it where what were you physically uh we
wrote it in australia
this was
supported by
three or four visits to the united
states by julie where she went and
interviewed the people that we had
tracked down in their hometown so she
traveled all over america uh recording
people's comments and collecting data
and so on
so we tried to make the the book as
complete and accurate as possible why
did julie have this kind of time
is this a full-time job
we made it a full-time job we decided
that it was such an important message
that uh that you know the war has
changed so significantly from the time
that say my ancestors came to america in
1622
and landed at james city and they were
firing old musket weapons at that the
indians and the indians were fighting
firing bows and air arrows back at them
and
but by the time i was to leave the
military we had awesome weapons in our
inventory that one alone could
bring about the destruction of humankind
we saw what chernobyl brought about well
that would if chernobyl was a bomb that
was on a submarine or an airplane or at
the end of a of a missile it would be a
very small one in what the soviets and
the americans and the in the english and
so on have in their inventory so i felt
that we had to bring out the point that
that that through our story of war is no
longer probably the means to resolve
conflict we got to find a new way to do
it and that's kind of one of the bottom
lines of the book did you spend some of
your own money to keep this thing going
oh we sure did and
the advance was small because simon and
schuster
didn't know us from adam we had never
written a book before of any
significance and
so the advance was it was really small
and
julie dipped into her savings and
luckily i was retired army so i had a my
little magic blue check coming in every
month
and that's what kept us going
somewhere i read that you moved to
australia and became a millionaire
several times over is that true well jim
webb said that and and and i know he
worked hard to do his research uh you're
talking about the parade magazine yeah
that's right uh but i think that's an
era and i'm glad you're going to correct
it to the nation
i
did do well
but i don't didn't do well in those kind
of numbers i use my military experience
and my military training which i found
that were very uh
appropriate and applicable to civilian
life if you thought things out and made
your decisions rationally and
logically it was very easy to be a
success so i used my military training
and and uh running restaurants and
establishing a duck farm and and so on
and
i found that civilian life is a piece of
cake
why'd you come home
well i came home mainly to be to promote
the book but
i think an important part of this which
i didn't understand
last may my son graduated from school
and i came to
to his graduation in berkeley and
at the same time brought the manuscript
back the final manuscript to simon
schuster and
then i left there and went out to
montana to spend a few days with my best
friend and
i suddenly realized that i wanted to
come home that the book had had such a
cathartic effect on me it's such a
healing effect
such a purging effect that
it had taken all of the bitterness out
it had taken all of the the
need to
strike out and get revenge for what
happened and
and i realized that i wanted to return
home and return to my roots and in this
score from that parade piece uh i've
received hundreds of letters and many of
the the people writing those letters had
uh
uh
read the book
because the the article told about the
book and so many vietnam veterans
so many
wives of soldiers that were killed in
vietnam
parents of soldiers who were killed in
vietnam uh
wrote to me and said that the book had a
healing effect for them and i'm really
thrilled with this that here maybe we've
explained what happened and now to
parents who over all of these years have
thought my god uh why did my son die and
what were the circumstances and once as
one lieutenant wrote to me said now i
understand
i felt so guilty over all of these years
that i was the one who told men to die
and they followed my orders and i
realized that i was fighting in a in a
bad war maybe in an unjust war in a war
that perhaps my country shouldn't have
been in in the first place
so i'm glad that that kind of message is
coming out of it because that's the kind
of uh
effect it's had on me brian
are you home for good you're dying to
where are you going to live i think in
montana or colorado some some place up
high where i can be out in the country i
like i like the uh wilderness and i'm
not into the big cities i i've just been
in new york for three or four days
i couldn't sleep from all the noise
because i live in australia on top of a
little hill all by myself
and i hear a car coming down the the
road they're coming to see me and i
don't hear that many cars coming down
the road so suddenly to be thrust in new
york city where they're collecting the
the garbage at midnight and there's
crash bang boom uh it was like living on
a battlefield so i'll live probably uh
up in the hills where my family came
from
so i'm really had this passion to return
to my roots
on the cover of your book and obviously
inside
down at the bottom you have
with an introduction by ward just
who is ward jest and why did you ask him
to do this introduction
ward just as uh
a writer he wrote for a newsweek
washington post he's now a novelist and
a very good one and we're just had a
profound
influence on my life
it started with
in june of 1966
during the battle of dokto
ward was with one of my platoons the
reconnaissance platoons that found
themselves in a very tough fire fight
deep into
enemy positions and they were surrounded
and had a great number of casualties and
ward
was wounded in this action and that
night
we couldn't get to the to this uh
besieged unit uh
with infantry to reinforce them we were
working towards that end
and they had the unit had eight
seriously wounded men and who in the
terms of the medic that was on the
ground
reckoned they wouldn't make it till
first light when we could get them out
with chopra so we've got an
all-volunteer air force chopper crew
that flew over the battlefield took a
lot of fire but winched him out and well
i thought that this reporter would come
out too
uh and he refused and he gave up his
seat so a fellow in his judgment who was
more severely wounded could get out he
stayed on the ground stayed surrounded
and so on when he had a free ticket out
which was so un atypical to reporters in
vietnam and he won me for life and he
joined the brotherhood he joined the the
brotherhood of infantrymen and when the
fight was over i went to the hospital i
awarded him the combat infantry badge i
took him a rifle that we had captured in
the fight a chinese rifle and
he became my friend for life and then
coincidentally i was from that
assignment assigned to the pentagon
right here in this city and uh as was
ward he became the washington post
military correspondent so we dealt a lot
together and i
learned from him he wrote his very
brilliant book to what end and he asked
me to review the manuscript and then i
realized the war wasn't only a war of
tactics and and strategy but a war of
winning the people to the side of the
government of south vietnam and there
were so many other uh political
implications other than the wham bam on
the of the battlefield and so
ward became my teacher and and and it
caused me to kind of wake up and uh
so that
i knew that he had the sensitivity to to
write an introduction that would uh
really tell what our book was all about
for some reason i found myself in the
macarthur museum in norfolk virginia a
couple days ago
and
saw a film prepared by the museum
that showed general macarthur during the
korean war and at one point
watching this they showed the general
incheon
and the comment voiced over
something the effect the this was one of
the smartest things that general
macarthur did in korea was to land the
troops at incheon
strong it was even stronger than that
you talked about generals earlier what
do you think of general macarthur
well i think that that
there are a lot of arguments about what
happened at incheon
meanwhile back at the busan perimeter
we were getting stronger and stronger so
we were about to break out anyway and he
took an enormous risk
to employ
the forces that he did against the
recommendations of the navy by the
marine corps
it was a very daring thing to do and it
might have been a desperate thing to do
i think what happened to general
macarthur was he became a law unto
himself i think that he he
uh had developed to the point where he
didn't have to follow orders and this
the thing about a soldier is you must
follow orders and i think that would
experience that with macarthur at a much
lower level we experienced it with
oliver north
his failure to follow the constitution
his failure to follow
the instructions that he received the
law and once you go beyond the law when
you've got
military forces at your disposal
our only purpose as soldiers is to
defend this country and when you start
doing things on your own
you're violating your charter
you talk about in your own book when you
were
a soldier where you would do things
beyond i mean i i don't care where i
read it maybe there was a jim webb piece
uh
where you would stretch the law or
stretch the rules too i never yeah i
always broke the rules okay i was never
a soldier that followed the rules but
there's a difference between breaking an
army regulation
then breaking a law of our country and
violating the constitution and that's
why when i became so frustrated over
what was happening in vietnam
i didn't shred the constitution i stood
and took the message to the people
because i believed and this was the
thing that hurt me that we were a nation
of the people by the people and for the
people and what our nation was all about
was exactly that and that's the thing
that i found scary that the people were
asleep
and the people were not in charge and
they left the running of our government
to the generals to the politicians to
the presidents and so on and i think
that they
those cats need us to tell them what to
do and if we think they're in charge
we're making a mistake because this
country should be run by the people
that's what democracy is all about
you said earlier that the generals
take their orders from the civilians
the soldier takes his order from the
ball i mean
how can you have a successful war if the
generals aren't running the show
well it's a prerequisite of the general
the guy in charge
to ensure
that uh
if he's in a war that he's he's fighting
the war as effectively as frugally as uh
brilliant leads and swiftly as possible
the call key to war it's not a very
complicated thing it's get there first
with the mostess
grab your enemy by the short of the
stock and give him a punch that he won't
forget and make a real impression on him
now when you do that you've got the
initiative on your side what has
happened in our military is that uh that
since 1946 we've become uh
our generals have removed themselves
from the war
they've become as i said earlier
corporate generals they become people
who are involved in the politics of
things
rather than the war of things and in
becoming politicians they're
they've developed kind of a
go along to get along attitude and now
this is wrong what what a general should
do
if i am your general and you have tasked
me to fight in vietnam let's use that
situation then i would say
mr president you realize the security of
our country is not at stake there why
are we fighting there and you say well
we've got to contain communism there and
then i would argue that perhaps we
wouldn't be containing communism there
but if you said general it's my
instructions that you will fight there i
say right sir i will deploy my forces
accordingly now i need to fight there 12
divisions of infantry i want to deploy
them simultaneously and i need to
destroy the port of haipyong i need to
destroy the the the dykes and the red
river delta i need to destroy sonukville
the port i need to
destroy all of the enemy sanctuaries and
the president would say well we can al
allow you to have those divisions we
will allow you to use your navy to
blockade and destroy hypyong and then i
then it is my obligation to say i can't
go into that war with these two mighty
fists tied behind my back if you won't
allow me to do it correctly and to win i
quit find another boy
and then i would quit and you'd find
another boy and if he felt if we had
those kind of warriors and that's what
ridgeway would have said and he did say
that in 1954 when we uh our
administration was considering going
into that war and that is what patton
would have said and that's the kind of
generalship we need we don't need
corporate generals we need warrior
generals that know and are willing to
stand in the door who are willing to say
that piece of equipment is junk i mean
why today are we spending for example a
half a billion dollars on a bomber the
stealth bomber when they're not even
sure it'll fly or why we're spending
hundreds of millions of dollars on the
b1 bomber and they're grounded to be
used only in war or why we have tanks
and like the the sergeant york uh
divisional and anti-aircraft system
which cost two billion dollars was
quietly folded up because it didn't work
but after the taxpayer had spent that
kind of money so if if you had generals
who knew what the hell they were doing
you wouldn't have these problems so what
we've got to inculcate and what our
congress has to do and they're at fault
in this whole military procurement thing
too is they've got to insist that we
produce those kind of people and those
are the kind of people that we put stars
on their shoulders that the fighters
from the past not the writers from the
present and the future
what
um if you're president united states how
do you know
that a general
has the right judgment when they come
back at you but what what makes you
think that the president and the
civilians don't have the right answer
and they are ordering the generals to
carry out their mission
and if just because the general comes
back and says i'm not going to do that
does that make the general right well
he's got it the generals simply can't
say i won't do that but they'll give the
reasons why
and and
and then they're willing in the european
sense
to resign if it's if it's not done
correctly
but we
we have
developed
a system of selection of our generals
that you must have a master's degree you
must have gone to the war college and
have you been to harvard and have you
had all of these different experiences
so by the time you are a general you've
forgotten what it is to lead troops and
we'll take westmoreland for example who
i think is a great corporate general on
the battlefield of europe he would have
probably been another eisenhower he's a
good man i'm not saying that he's a bad
man but he was the wrong fellow for that
show
in vietnam but if you take a guy like
like westmoreland
his whole background is one of an
administrator
certainly he had the cursory uh
command experiences but he didn't know
what was going on the ground his
background was he was an artillerymen
he had never been an infantry platoon an
f3 company in an infantry battalion in
his life but yet he was the leader of a
war which was purely an infantry war
fought at those levels so he was it was
like a car designer that had never
driven a car and many of our divisions
were commanded in vietnam by those type
people who simply didn't know their
trade they may have at one time and i
think one of the problems is
most of the generals in vietnam were the
young colonels of world war ii the best
and the brightest and uh by the time
they were 23 24 years old they were a
lieutenant colonel today a fellow who's
23 years old is a lieutenant and he'll
probably be able to attend it for a
couple more years so he's getting a lot
of experience at platoon level patton
said an officer wasn't worth a pinch of
salt until he had 10 years with troops
and but our our soldiers and our
officers and leaders today don't get
that kind of experience i think today
right now in 1989 the army has
recognized this now just been to the
seventh division at the 25th division
and the national training center out at
fort irwin and i've talked to the young
leaders and these people are good and
they're and the and the battalion
commanders that i spoke to had been with
their battalions a long time and were
eminently qualified and i think where it
happens is once they leave battalion and
they become a bird colonel or above
that's where the corruption begins and
then these are the fellows who become
the generals and and they're the ones
who go along to get along and won't
stand in the door
you've just joined us we're talking with
retired colonel david hackworth this is
his book it's called about face the
odyssey
of an american warrior
co-authored with julie sherman
go back to let's let's quickly go over
for those people who have just joined us
your
military experience you came in when
you're 15 years old you first served in
italy 1946 46 to 15. you were not in
world war ii nope came at the end of
world war just as when the war ended
came in as a
listed yep
you got a battlefield commission where
in korea what was your first rank uh
on the on the battlefield i was a squad
leader then a platoon sergeant and a
platoon leader and then a company
commander and
i was trained in in and tries
in almost a time warp
it was an isolated command all of the
ncos were kind of bert lancaster from
here to eternity kind of guys
non-commissioned officers the
non-commissioned officers all of the
officers were eminently qualified from
the war combat veterans and so on so i
thought that was what the army was all
about meaning i thought the whole united
states army was like trieste but what
what it was italy and trieste in italy
yeah it was called trust united states
troops tries to united states troops and
uh when i left that command i was well
trained in the basics and my platoon
sergeant would
beat it into our heads if you don't
learn it right you won't do it right and
we learned it right by repetition by
iron discipline
and by great motivation great spirit so
i took those values and for the next 21
years imposed them on any unit that i uh
served in and i was always in trouble
for being too tough for being to to
discipline but i'll tell you one thing
brian very few of my soldiers died
because i made damn certain they were
well trained and if you're going to have
an army then that's their function you
got to make certain they're well trained
if you have an electrical company that
that that's playing with electricity you
want to make damn well sure that all
your electricians have played with
electricity before and know that if they
touch the wrong thing they're dead how
much formal education do you have
seventh grade
at that time seventh grade yes how about
now uh university degree the the army
was incredibly good to me uh they
educated me they sent me to university i
went to austin p university in in uh
tennessee and uh got a degree in history
and and so
i'm not just knocking the army in terms
of
attacking an institution i i have a
great love for this institution because
it
it was my home it looked after me and i
just want to make sure that we'd never
repeat the mistakes of the past i think
the united states army will ever fight
again in a conventional war
well that's hard to say and i don't have
a crystal ball i don't think that i
don't think you'll see a war between
superpowers i think that both the soviet
union and the united states realize that
that the destructive powers that they
they have at the end of their cannons is
so so mind-boggling that it would
destroy uh destroy the their countries
and to destroy the world somebody told
me but i do think if i just
finish that i do think that we will see
wars of national liberation similar to
what we had in vietnam i think we'll see
wars in latin america latin america is
exploding and i think that that that is
where our strategic interest was really
threatened and i think that we need
forces who know how to deal with that
and more important we need diplomats
right here in your city who can solve
the matter without conflict who can
solve the matter through
programs of education and and
stopping this whole gringo thing of the
of the arrogant yank coming in and and
uh uh
taking advantage of somebody that
doesn't have the good things that we
have i think that we there a lot can be
done
uh in latin america to preclude a war
but i think we've got to be prepared for
that contingency how long were you in
korea
i was there in 1950 51 52 i went to fort
benning for uh in 1952
beginning
yeah just kind of like a mid-level
chorus on infantry which went from the
company to regiment and then i went back
to korea 52-53 how long were we in
vietnam 65 through
all of 65-66
60 part of 67 then 69 70 and half of 71.
what did we not learn from korea or
there's probably a better way to ask
that but what mistakes do we make in
korea well that's a very very good
question because
in korea
we made a lot of a lot of mistakes we
simply we went there with the view that
well here comes uncle sam we've just
kicked the japs and the germans tale and
we anybody gets in our way uh it was
like john wayne and top gun type thing
uh better stand aside and we thought our
presence which would stop the north
koreans as we did the same in vietnam as
we did recently in lebanon our presence
would would cool things off and uh
we sent an army that was badly trained
badly led by a lot of tired old men and
badly equipped that hadn't been trained
for the battlefield and we made a lot of
mistakes and the things didn't turn
around until we got a leader ridgeway
and when general walker was killed
ridgeway took over and he turned one in
one of the most
important
events of military history how one man
can take a defeated army and turn it
around that's why leadership is threaded
through this discussion so much if you
got the right leader you can get the job
done go back to general ridgeway though
and just tell me what you liked about
him as a leader he was on the
battlefield he knew his trade
meaning he knew what what the tactics
were about he knew what strategy was
about and he was not afraid afraid to
tell the president of the united states
truman at that time when things were not
going right did you know him i never
knew him personally but i've admired him
and i served under his command and of
course in the 8th army how many people
did you have command over in korea
in korea or the most would be a rifle
company a couple hundred men
and what technique did you use
leadership technique did you use in
korea that you can remember that people
responded to
i talked to my soldiers i was there i
would never give an order that
that that i wouldn't do myself and and i
love my soldiers i never wasted them
they knew that and
we
we
formed a very perfect team i was very
hard on them meaning i was like a father
that
that uh
uh took his children and and laid a uh
a very disciplined trip on him but we
were not playing in the backyard we were
playing in a life and death game and if
i could train them where they were
competent and confident then i knew they
could make it through the night into the
most horrible experience that a human
can endure and that's being an
infantryman on the battlefield when
shells are crashing in booby traps are
exploding machine guns are ripping away
so it's it's a it's a one big raging
atrocity brian
based on what your experience was
did you ever change the way you led
troops after korea i always led from the
front and and that was ridgeway's way of
leading and physically go to the front
physically ahead of them oh well
i
uh
in
the the delta of vietnam when i took
over battalion that was so badly trained
it was filled with draftees and bad
leadership and so on that i virtually
had to become a squad leader again
meaning i virtually had to lead from the
front but as soon as i got him trained
up i got back to where i could command
you know you really can't uh fight
a battalion or a brigade by playing
squad leader you've got to get back and
look at the battle and see it see it
from an overview point but there's
always a time that you've got to go and
understand the pulse of it you've just
got to grab onto the pulse of the fight
and to find out what's going on the
great generals of history the the
jacksons and the rommels and the
ridgeways and the gavins and so on were
guys who led from the front not from
their helicopter as was in vietnam or
not from the command-and-control bunker
that's in the pentagon they were there
and they knew what was going on and they
had a good feel for the war another man
who was outspoken in vietnam
who has been now the subject of another
very successful book neil shins
bright shining light john paul vann
got out as lieutenant colonel came back
as a major general in the civilian world
well he knew him well he was my company
commander in korea for a while and i
worked with him in the delta and i as a
guy i admired a great deal why
he was one of the kind of guys that we
were talking about he wasn't afraid to
stand up and tell the truth he flew
around one of those planes oh yeah but
uh
that's uh when he was was killed uh and
i flew around one of those planes too
but i wasn't reluctant to land the damn
thing and get on the ground and leave my
troops nor was john paul van he was a
doer a shaker and an and a a maker and i
i liked him and they i thought he was a
good man neil sheen gives you a mixed
picture though on him well neil shannon
goes into his uh
personal background and uh
i don't know if i cared for all of that
but i didn't write the book that's up
for to neil sheehan to say what he had
to say but i think i enjoyed the book
very much and i think that our book
certainly dovetails very neatly with it
as a companion piece
because we're talking about the war from
the standpoint of the u.s where that was
the vietnamese side even though we have
one strong chapter that deals with arvin
and the vietnamese and and
from my almost uh two plus years
experience working as an advisor at
brigade and division and special zone
level in vietnam with the vietnamese
you
what do you think men in
the military in a war situation respond
to
the best personal relationship tough
versus
loud versus quiet all those little
things that people study when it comes
to leadership what was your style did
you scream and yell at them no i don't
think a lot done by screaming and
yelling i think that
by setting the example
by
winning their confidence letting them
know that you're not a butcher that you
love them that you're going to care for
them and uh
uh and that you really know your trade
and once your soldiers know that okay
and i'll give you a good story that that
that's told in and about faces is i
taken over this battalion this one i
described to draftees and on the first
day and i just couldn't believe the
condition of this unit was just total
disintegration and i
uh
reckoned that their defensive positions
were wouldn't hack it if we were tapped
if the enemy hit us uh we'd we'd be in
serious trouble so my first order after
taking over the unit was
by midnight i want us to be fall fall
back 300 yards i want new positions dug
and and i went all this junk taken out
there was there was uh
cokes and and uh soft drinks and little
containers on position the men slept in
cots
the weapons were rusty ammunition was in
the mud it was just simply not a
professional military organization it
was an organization that had been
blooded for six months and they were
just waiting for a disaster so i fell
them back they dug in their nose and
their their new holes got their new
positions together with a lot of
grumbling who is this new guy that they
would call me gi joe who's gonna
change this thing around and blow our
nice soft life apart and uh the uh
exactly at midnight that night as if i
would have planned it we got hit with
everything that the enemy could throw at
us with rockets and with artillery and
fire of all sorts and the men went to
their defensive position and now i had
been away from troops uh
from combat troops okay i had a
battalion at fort
lewis
just before i came to vietnam on this
tour but i'd been away from the war for
a couple years and and i was nervous as
nelly you know i was grabbed the radio i
thought geez i hope i don't blow this
thing here's with all my combat
experience so you can imagine these
dilettantes that came in who hadn't been
with troops for 10 or 15 years and took
a battalion okay
and
as i was
adjusting artillery and calling in air
and getting flare ships and all these
good things you do and under those
circumstances a young lieutenant ran by
to go into his fighting position and he
said i'll tell you what he's a mean son
of a [ __ ] but he knows what he's doing
and that that was success and that you
know yeah and the next day the grumbling
slowed down and that those words were
probably spread throughout the battalion
that i knew what i was doing and if we
had more people
in vietnam that knew what they were
doing
i think the outcome of that war at the
tactical level on the battlefield would
have been a lot different we would have
come out with with real honor rather
than the the kissinger peace with honor
meaning where we sold out our allies
if you had to pick a general that's in
the united states army today that's your
kind of general you got anybody i got
lots of them name a couple oh sure
there's jim musselman johnny howard
jim bukiyama
kids that i knew who were young
lieutenants young majors and so on don
hilbert right here in your city they've
got a lot of
very confident guys i'm very pleased
with the
number of the generals that i know that
i've soldiered with glenn mallory i
could and i could name probably a dozen
so i think i think that the
somebody who's picking generals or
picking the kind of guys who will stand
in the door and who'll give us
uh who bring back that warrior leader
spirit that we had in this country
before the patents and the ridgeways
back in 1971 you went on issues and
answers
to say
had you planned to say the strong things
about the vietnam war that you did
well
i had
a lot of time to ruminate about it and
it was a hell of a decision because i
knew i was cutting my throat in terms of
the military i knew i was all washed up
if i sounded off but i felt it was
necessary that i did and so i did my
homework and i
mean
i knew i was going to talk about
training i was going to talk about
vietnamization i was going to talk about
how the war was being fought about the
bad senior leadership and
so
when it came to to
filming it i i had my
act together where'd you do it right in
vietnam in the mekong delta you remember
who interviewed you
yeah a guy named howard tuchner from abc
and his uh
nick george
who was the abc bureau chief who later
and nick george was very responsible for
i think
uh
probably keeping me alive because the
army became immediately angry and a lot
of funny things happened to me and uh
nick george just simply assigned a
camera team and a and a uh
narrator to me and wherever i went along
with this abc team and i had the power
of the press it was a great insurance
policy in my back pocket did they know
when they assigned the crew to you that
you're going to sound off
oh well
the abc people
had been
asking me for about three months to do
this interview and i was trying to weigh
up
whether i wanted to
pay the price
or go to war college and get a star and
go onward and upwards how did they know
by the way that you
lord jess wrote a book
called military men i don't know if you
remember that book and there was a
chapter in there called the colonel it
didn't mention me by name but
and he tried to to shape me so you
couldn't uh like he made me five foot
nine and
changed my uh appearance a bit and so on
uh but
among the media they knew that that was
david hackworth so and they knew those
words were mine and they could feel the
anger and what they were trying to do is
get me to be the first senior guy to
sound off and uh in retrospect i'm glad
i did it i i'm sure that
i
caused us to get out of that mess a
little bit earlier
a minute left
what's been
the reaction to the
to the by the military to this book and
has anybody not liked it and come and
told you so
the reaction to the military the current
military
that's
running things right in your town has
been very favorable they allowed me
first of all general bagnell commanders
of western command out in the pacific
invited me out there to talk on my
vietnam experience to talk about how to
fight the guerrilla to his commanders
and staff i visited the 25th division
the seventh division by invitation of
their commanders i visited the
national training center uh so i think
that the i i'm i'm actually rather
surprised that they're letting somebody
who had once uh gave them a good blast
in the nose back but i think that they
think that
there's some good lessons learned in
this book and that and they can learn
something from me so uh
they've forgiven me and i i've forgiven
them and remember the guys running the
army today weren't the generals in
vietnam they were the majors who were
mumbling and grumbling and bitching and
moaning just like i was they knew the
truth the book about face the odyssey of
an american warrior colonel david h
hackworth u.s army retired and julie
sherman thank you very much for your
time my pleasure
david hackworth is a syndicated
columnist for king features his other
works include vietnam primer which was
published by the pentagon and used as a
training manual during the vietnam war
his book pictured here about face the
odyssey of an american warrior is
currently available in paperback from
simon schuster trade
every weekend book tv brings you an
encore presentation of c-span's book
notes program
encore book notes airs saturdays at 7
p.m and sundays at 11 a.m eastern here
on c-span 2.
next week historian michael beschloss
has booked the crisis years examines the
relationship between president kennedy
and soviet leader nikita khrushchev and
its impact on the cold war